Gina Carano sues Disney Lucas film Elon
Musk will facilitate others joining the
lawsuits this is uh it's an eventful day
I gotta say it's Tuesday so it's it's
news day here what was that Phil's got
speakers blast my bad check this out
actress Gina corano filed a lawsuit
against lucas films and Disney with the
aid of ex-owner Elon Musk she said uh
the actress announced her lawsuit on in
a Tuesday expost after my 20 years of
building a career from scratch and
during the regime of former Disney CEO
Bob chapek Lucas film made this
statement on Twitter terminating me from
the Mandalorian quote Gina corano is not
currently employed by lucasfilm and
there are no plans for her to be in the
future nevertheless her social media
posts denigrating People based on their
cultural and religious identities are
abhorent and unacceptable Gano wrote
citing Lucas film statement now here's
here's the thing she never said those
things Gina Crono never denigrated
anybody never insulted anybody and she
points this out in a long expost where
she she says I never used aggressive
language I shared thought-provoking
quotes pictures memes and I occasionally
occasionally used my words not with
aggression but with respect and the
occasional comedy to keep the mood light
she mentions that in one instance she
said beep bop boop which is in no way
here we go she says so what did I do uh
she says I was I was called a transphobe
for making Droid noises from Star Wars
beat bot boot was obviously directed to
the online bullies and did not in any
way denigrate transgender people but
they did fire fire her she says a couple
months ago Elon Musk tweeted that if you
had been fired from the platform from uh
fired I think she means for using the
platform acts for exercising your right
to free speech he would like to offer
these people legal representation quite
the noble offer but never in my wildest
dreams would I have thought anyone would
take take on my case against Lucas film
in Disney still I did respond back I
think I qualify and thousands of people
agreed but I didn't expect anything to
my surprise a few months ago IED an
email from a lawyer who had been hired
by X to look into my story and many
others turns out out after sending them
as much information as I could I could
gather these past few months my now
lawyers and ex believe wholeheartedly in
my case and are moving forward I would
like to express my deepest gratitude and
thank you to Elon Musk and X for giving
me the opportunity to bring my case to
light as for me I would like to pick up
where I left off and continue my journey
of creating and participating in
storytelling which is my utmost passion
and everything I worked for it has been
difficult to move forward with the lies
and labels Stuck on Me backed and
encouraged by the most powerful
entertainment company in the world I am
grateful someone has come to my defense
in such a powerful way and look forward
to clearing my name it would appear the
reporting I've seen is that she is
seeking to be recast let me make sure we
have that is that uh I believe that's
the uh perhaps not I saw that Hollywood
Reporter that should she win the lawsuit
she would want to be recast uh on the
show Mandalorian I don't know if that if
that is exactly what's happening here
but Elon Musk isn't stopping there he
tweeted if you were discriminated
against by Disney or its subsidiaries
ABC ESPN Marvel Etc just replied to this
post to receive legal
support wow this is going to be big uh I
want to just say as we get into this uh
because we also we can read this post he
put up from Disney it's good for
business there are a lot of people who
are scared to use Twitter X let's let
we'll stop deadnaming the platform you
know we're almost there they're scared
because they're going to get fired this
is Elon musk's one of his smartest
business moves it's not even about the
culture War I mean I'm sure it is
honestly but I'm sure at the company
there are some business-minded
individuals who asked Elon why sue for
people getting fired from the platform
and Elon said look how many people would
be on the platform verified with their
profile picture paying $8 a month if
they were confident they would not be
fired for speaking up a lot of people
who use the platform won't sign up out
of fear it will connect to them and then
when they express their opinions they
will lose their lives we defend them
when they get fired and they'll feel
more comfortable will get more users
we'll get more paying subscribers not to
mention Elon Musk probably said think of
the ideological press when we announce
we're doing this every person who
opposes this this anti-free speech is
going to sign up to support us because
they know that that money is helping to
fund pushing back against cancel
culture I mean maybe um I think that I'm
I'm starting to think that he's he's got
a chip on his shoulder now I mean he is
in a position where he's got the federal
government uh you know starting to
really look at him and he's he's getting
pressure from the administration and
when the president is you know making
remarks about you saying things like
we're going to look into you that's a
pretty intimidating kind of thing so I
think that there's probably a lot of
personal uh in impulse there you know
but uh I mean maybe he is I don't know
I'm for it what do you guys think of
course I'm for it the main thing I think
is that if she wants to get her job back
and get recast that that would be a very
hostile work environment for her even if
they are forced to do it legally I don't
know why she would want that that's what
recast means someone else right well no
I don't know if it's true he said
Hollywood Reporter Tim mentioned me said
that she wanted to get her old role back
be recast in the RO yeah I want to make
sure I'm trying to fact check that
because uh I had seen that it's an
interesting demand yes uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah H reporter Chrono brings a claim of
wrongful discharge and sex
discrimination she seeks a court order
that would force lucasfilm to recast her
and at least $75,000 plus punitive
damages interesting yeah it's
interesting maybe it wouldn't be a
hostile work I mean she might be friends
with all those guys yeah and like it was
the producer that she didn't even know
that fired her that no even knew or
something like that oh right right right
somebody made a phone call and then they
came to her and they're probably like
Gina we're sorry I mean they're they're
telling us you're out and she was
probably like what the man that's that's
probably crazy and the crazy thing about
it is she's pointed out she did not we
we read this she didn't say the things
they claimed she said the the big
egregious violation was when she posted
uh it was like an image from the
Holocaust and it said do not be tricked
into condemning your neighbors and they
were like she's comp compare comparing
Republicans to Jews in the Holocaust
which she was not she was literally
making a a broad statement of the
government will trick you into being
enemies with your with fellow people Y
and that's like a common occupy leftist
Trope Y where the where the government
corporations want to put the people
against each other yeah I mean not not
to get into the the metaphysical too
deeply or whatever but this this kind of
points to the the argument that the that
the word has power that the ab that just
having the ability to articulate things
can make things manifest in reality what
they did was they said look she said all
these anti-semitic things and even
though the content was not anti-semitic
the the point of it was not anti-semitic
and there's no evidence that it was just
people saying look this connection to
you know the the Holocaust means that
she's insensitive means that she's
anti-semitic and it it got enough people
concerned enough where they the where
you know the higher upset Disney said
okay you've got to go where they just
and because all the estimation is is
just is this worth us defending is it
worth us fighting for I want to I want
to just stress this point that um there
are journalists out there I'll see a
news headline and it'll say something
like Donald Trump uh you know ordered
drone strike blah blah blah and I'll be
like wow that's big and then I will
click the story and in the first
paragraph it will start with it was a
dark and stormy night oh God A Midsummer
Tuesday scroll down to the end of that
paragraph the next one by the end of the
third paragraph they tell you what it's
about you exactly and we've all
experienced this and I bring this up
because I give you the lawsuit
introduction a short time ago in a
Galaxy not so far away done I skipped to
the end of the paragraph immediately and
see if it's topical
i w come on was just descriptive
defendants made it clear that only one
Orthodoxy in thought speech and action
was acceptable in their empire and that
those who dared to question or failed to
fully no you lost me I now I now oppose
Elon Musk I am going full Democrat I'm a
leftist now because of that wonder if he
let grock write this thing I have cancer
now sounds like it and it's probably
terminal I'm if I make can't believe
they did that in the open oh man that
sounds like grock wrote it that's funny
I wonder if he Ed grock to write that if
I got to be honest like if I was a judge
and I I would be really pissed off I
would be so don't waste my time would be
too no flowy words give me the nuts are
they are they expecting that their Jud
the judge is going to be like a Star
Wars nerd or something oh that was very
clever it is not clever at all so what
else we got
cancer terminal in so they say in her
post she expressed her personal
political views opinions beliefs and
retaliation for her exercise of her
speech rights defendant terminated
carano's uh carano's employment and took
other retaliatory actions to limit and
deny her future employment opportunities
including but not limited to making
maliciously false statements about Coran
corano with the intention of damaging
her reputation and thus her ability to
find and retain work I think that's the
important factor here I'm willing to bet
it was an activist at the company who
was like okay we're going to fire her it
doesn't matter if she did anything wrong
and then the statement that went out
saying she made aggressive you know she
made these disparaging comments was to
defame her quite literally because she
never did and I I don't know what lawyer
would sign off on a def a defamatory
statement like that now I think it was
an activist who just went for it maybe
definitely who else do you think might
join in a lawsuit like this I mean are
there are there any other like people we
could think of to get her fired you know
people that have been wrong by Disney
yes yes that Elon
ESPN well I mean theoretically I mean I
don't know what anyone that might have
been on that
uh the the series that she was supposed
to be in they were going to make car
pasc anybody that was supposed to be in
the series they might be able to be like
hey I was supposed to be a grip on that
series or I was supposed to be this on
that series or they might be able to
make a a monetary claim this is just you
know hyp hypothetical but otherwise I
don't know you know yeah I don't know I
suppose you could argue that
uh yeah these secondary jobs that were
were cut because she was removed from
the show or something I don't know
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net